I want to start the show with some good
news ladies w ready for that there are
no more presidential debates
[Applause]
[Music]
fantastic it's gonna hurt the zinger
industry though we got four more years
before we got to go through that again
great they needed nine more I think
before we could really decide now I
don't know who watched last night did
you see this IATA Blee heard a guy go
yeah what's that
this guy right here yeah it's convention
on a TV show applaud or not yeah
you think you're watching television
right now don't you
you forgot this is really happening this
clown
I gotta go to the bathroom I was some
some debate me if you didn't see it let
me talk about it for a few minutes to
alienate you yes it was crazy at one
point during the debate last night
moderator Bob Schieffer accidentally
said Obama bin Laden yeah it was right
after he called Romney Adolph Midler
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that was pretty good cuz a Hitler
yeah I like this everyone's talking
about this part during last night's
debate President Obama told Mitt Romney
the 1980s called and they want their
foreign policy back
yeah Mitt Romney tried to deliver a
comeback but then his beeper went off
yeah he had to fact Pat Benatar yeah I'm
sorry I lost him again as we get closer
to election day a lot of crazy rumors
are starting to surface about the two
candidates today this one was going
around a man is claiming that President
Obama used and sold cocaine in college
yeah on the bright side if this is true
it means Obama does have business
experience today a poll found that
President Obama won last night's debate
among a voting block known as Walmart
moms that's true and Mitt Romney won the
debate according to the voting bloc
wouldn't be caught dead at Walmart moms
these are important voting blocks Andy
you still here I'm still here
sometimes Andy wanders away for a while
prices cars makes a sandwich I got the
band with me right now of course they're
kind of paid to enjoy the show
Andy's paid to enjoy the show and not
laughing at all check out this one gang
a group this one's no good all right
[Applause]
I checked out what when it was and then
oh yeah hey you're gonna love this a
group of scientists has named a new type
of plant after lady gaga
yeah it's a plant called Madonna imitate
us
[Applause]
then I mentioned no more debates for
four more years
today Domino's gave out a half million
slices of free pizza yeah yeah then
later today everybody gave them back he
said one bite out of it although I heard
some people appear gasping joy that's
the first thing I've said that made them
happy
free pizza a new study came out ladies
and gentlemen and it claims that 88% of
people's homemade pornography ends up on
porn sites without the owner's knowledge
yeah
which may explain why some of you look
familiar
[Applause]